hey this is Katie Drummond with bear
comm and I'm here today at the Army's
telemedicine and Advanced Technology
Research Center
we're with Colonel Cora panitch and he's
going to tell us a little bit more about
some of the programs they've got going
on a big project that I'd like to
emphasize katie is the use of technology
to capture vital science at the point of
injury in the battlefield right now in
Afghanistan if you can get to a level 3
or a Combat Support Hospital this is a
big field hospital you've got a 90%
chance of surviving your war wounds so
what we're trying to determine is what
happens to the 10% who don't survive on
the battlefield there are soldiers that
are deployed into a hot zone let's say
they get out of their armored vehicle
and they start walking through a
neighborhood and then if one of those
individuals gets shot or a bomb goes off
they capture that soldier and put them
into let's say an evacuation medical
ambulance and inside that ambulance is
the tempis pro physiological monitoring
device that's connected to the tactical
radio those vital signs are then
populating a trauma combat casualty care
card which contains the vital signs and
other information that the medical
corpsman may have used to treat the
patient for example I gave the patient
10 milligrams of morphine here's the
heart rate blood pressure pulse oximetry
all these different physiological
parameters that we measure that
electronic trauma combat casualty care
card is sent through tactical radio into
a higher level medical facility where
other doctors or nurses can look at the
results or that information can be
downloaded into the theater electronic
database which could then be used to
study how injuries are occurring and
ways to prevent them or improve outcomes
on the battlefield